hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt ein superschnelles und sehr
einfaches rezept und zwar mache ich
popup brötchen zum frühstück oder eben
auch zum thema also gestern hatten wir
sie zu unserer zeit um nachmittag und
zwar sind es ganz einfache brötchen aus
einem kunst da braucht man nur eier mehl
und etwas milch und dann noch zutaten
der wahl und die werden in so einer
speziellen backform gebacken das sieht
aus wie ein muffin backform ist ein
bisschen anders und preises von der form
her und bisschen höher aber auch normale
martin buck vom wird auf jeden fall
gehen bei uns ist es so wir gehen
sonntags meistens von meinen eltern zum
frühstück und nehmen da auch immer gerne
mal brötchen mit und dann kann ich eben
diese brötchen superschnell machen oder
wenn die eltern eben mal zu mir kommen
ja und ich ganz einfach den citrix ich
bin vor allem muss man ehrlich sagen für
mich sagt anteil an großen anteil an
eine ganz spezielle art des tages aber
es ist eigentlich ein pfannkuchenteig
also ein richtig flüssiger ich zeige
euch bei ihm die zutaten und dann
erzähle ich euch noch was für den teig
brauche ich zwei eier 260 milliliter
milch eine prise salz wobei sie eine
gute presse ist 140 gramm mehl ein paar
frische kräuter da hab ich jetzt
basilikum petersilie und minze steckt
hier noch mit drin und dann habe ich
hier noch einen käse das jetzt 150 gramm
tomaten käse
ihr könnt natürlich auch jeden anderen
käse nehmen aber ich nehme den immer
ganz gerne weil er es sehr würzig
schmeckt und gerade in diesen pacult in
bringt das auch richtig sind pep mit
rein also richtig gut wir mögen den
wirklich sehr gerne so ich werde zuerst
einmal den teig zubereiten das geht
wirklich super schnell dafür frühere ich
jetzt die milch und die eier
da kommt jetzt auch salz mit rein und
dann einfach mit einem schneebesen als
ihr braucht auch gar kein großes
equipment das geht ganz einfach
und bevor ich das jetzt vergessen muss
ich vorher die backform in den ofen
stellen und zwar habe ich den schon auf
220 grad ober unterhitze vorgeheizt und
die backform muss heiß sein
damit geht brötchen auch auspuffen also
einfach für etwa fünf minuten
jetzt kommt hier noch das mehl mit rein
jetzt alles klümpchen freue mich jedes
mal jedes nehmen also ich habe zwei
medien aber wir können zum beispiel auch
dinkel nehmen daneben da vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr milch der teig ist jetzt
schon fertig dass der grundstock mit dem
könnt ihr wirklich jetzt alles machen
bei mir kommen jetzt noch frische
kräuter mit rein und dann nimm dir
einfach die kräuter die ihr zuhause im
garten habt oder die bei euch in der
küche wachsen
man kann ja alles rein machen was ich
hatte mit man kann die dinge auch herz
machen was meine frau leider ja aber
herzhaft ist inzwischen ja man kann doch
jetzt ein paar tage frei machen oder
eine paste massen schinken
ich glaube deinen freunden er wird jetzt
vielleicht schmeckt mit reinhauen zum
beispiel kann man ja auch machen wo ich
da nicht fünf minuten sind jetzt vorbei
erzähle ich den teig fertig stellen
jetzt kommen die kräuterfee mit rein und
dann wird das ganze netz berührt
ganz vorsichtig
jetzt kurz mit etwas speiseöl oder backt
renz prey einfetten
und jetzt fühle ich die formen mit dem
teig und zwar etwa bis zur hälfte hatte
schon gesagt dass man seinen normalen
form machen können der normale form
nicht so schön hat eine ganz andere vor
richtig flüssiger tyce an patrick jetzt
kommt der käse an die reihe und zwar
nimmt jetzt zwei teelöffel und setzt da
jetzt immer so etwa einen halben
teelöffel vom käse mit rein
jetzt drücke ich denke so ein bisschen
rein und da können jetzt natürlich auch
zum beispiel frischkäse oder was anderes
nehmen also ganz anderen krise ricotta
auch aber durch den nomaden käse durch
diesen hüttenkäse wie das ganze etwas
wird sie ganz persönlich besser
jetzt kommt thomas zurück in den sack
nicht mit zehn minuten bei 200 winzer
und danach strich die hitze herunter und
stellt sie auf 180 ober unterhitze und
da werden sie noch einmal 15 minuten
weiter gebacken
richtig schön aufgegangen und jetzt
stelle ich die 110 minuten
die fünf minuten frühstücksbrötchen sind
jetzt gebracht
ich habe jetzt fünf frische kräuter
genannt weil ich habe nur fünf minuten
zubereitung sollte es nicht mehr die
sind schneller fertig als wie ich jetzt
zum wechsel auf und wieder zu stimmen
inzwischen hat kann einfach den tisch
decken
ja ich hab jetzt kurz ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen damit der morast
natürlich nicht verbrennt und schön wäre
es wenn ich nur die zuschauer noch
zusätzlich gewählt
das kann man auch machen gestern hatte
ich sie übrigens mit frischkäse gemacht
und da hatten so ein bisschen der pepp
gefährts wegen damals heute diesen
hüttenkäse den nomaden käse genommen
denn ich denke da schmeckt richtig gut
an wenn du da probieren
übrigens ist dieser marten käse da ist
ganz typisch für die startelf sind und
das hat auch einen bezug zu mir denn
meine mannschaft ist richtig schön
kräuter diese nomaden krise wirklich
lecker man kann auch ohne gar nichts
machen und einfach nur süß essen gilt
auch jetzt geht auch einladen dieses
grundrezept diesem grund steigt mit eier
mehl und prise salz und das war noch
drin
mit ihm kann man einfach so machen und
auch was süßes mit drei machen shops zum
beispiel oder einfach pur backen und
später mit marmelade essen
aber wie gesagt mit dem käse schmeckt
richtig wird sich richtig lecker den
bekommt man übrigens in jedem supermarkt
oder eben den türkischen supermärkten
gibt auch vom fehlen heißt homogene
genau also irgendwie hat es was vom
croissant irgendwie haben uns von
milchbrötchen es wird von porsche also
irgendwas ihm alles zwischendrin
schmeckt wirklich gigantisch als auch
mal richtig lecker
das bestätigt michaela total an so ein
windbeutel also außen so ley knusprig
und innen so richtig feucht teich oder
aber lecker lecker und so warnung dich
oder ja und war wo ich mein back
drittmittel nur 13
ich habe diese zutaten dir geheim
theoretisch könnte jeder mann kann es
auch in einer anderen form machen ist
jeder sofort machen also immer wenn ihr
mal nix da habt ein
auch mal schnell diese die man hier
nochmal das weg gefunden aber wirklich
gigantisch lecker es gab jetzt nicht
noch mal dazu einfach weil durch die
flecken ist schon seit monaten
also falls sie jetzt auch lust auf
dieses rezept bekommen habt geht auch
sallys - lockt stets noch mal ganz genau
für euch ich freue mich schon auf eure
kreationen und was ihr mir dann als foto
zu senden werden
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß beim nachbacken und wir sehen
uns aufs nächste mal bis dann irgendwann
klickst du einfach nur zwei kilo fisch
auf den teller oder irgendwas brauche
ich brauche nicht mehr
hoffentlich hengst